chile aumenta su pie de fuerza en la
frontera norte un decreto del gobierno
de Gabriel borich otorga facultades de
control migratorio a más de 600
efectivos militares para regular el paso
por rutas clandestinas en los límites
con Perú y Bolivia buena parte de ese
personal ya se encontraba en las
regiones más afectadas por el tránsito
de migrantes pero solo cumpliendo
funciones y asistencia a la policía el
estado de chile tenía un rezago
en el fondo nosotros tenemos en el norte
una falta de estado un estado
insuficiente para las necesidades de
esta región de acuerdo con este nuevo
decreto que estará en vigencia Por 90
días prorrogables con apoyo del Congreso
los efectivos militares podrán realizar
controles de identidad y detenciones
para frenar el aumento de la
criminalidad en la región chile retorna
a los extranjeros irregulares rechazados
por la misma vía por la que entraron
pero solo hacia Perú porque los vínculos
diplomáticos con Bolivia se limitan a
relaciones consulares Aquí hay una labor
diplomática que es complementaria lo que
estamos haciendo la que también estamos
trabajando arduamente que es para
establecer con Bolivia modalidades que
nos permitan reconducir a los
extranjeros que pasen de manera
irregular hoy cientos de personas la
mayoría venezolanas atraviesan pasos
ilegales en las regiones de antofagasta
taracapá y arica y parinacota decenas
han perdido la vida en el desierto de
atacama se calcula que un millón
cuatrocientos mil migrantes viven en
chile y representan actualmente el 7% de
la población total del país suramericano